pyloric stenosis is a disease in which
part of a baby stomach is blocked or
abnormally narrow located between the
esophagus and small intestine the
stomach stores and begins to digest milk
some of the main parts of the stomach
are the fundus
the body
the pyloric region
which includes the antrum and pyloric
canal
and the pylorus
the wall of the stomach contains several
layers of muscle
at the end of the pyloric region the
muscle layer forms a thickened ring
called the pyloric sphincter the pyloric
sphincter surrounds an opening to the
small intestine called the pylorus
the pyloric sphincter is normally
contracted just enough to hold milk in
the stomach while contractions mix and
break down the milk
from time to time stronger waves of
stomach contractions push milk out of
the stomach as the pyloric muscle
relaxants milk passes through the
pylorus into the small intestine
for unknown reasons some babies develop
pyloric stenosis in which abnormally
thickened muscle layers in the pyloric
sphincter block the pylorus
stomach contractions can't push milk
from the baby stomach through the
blocked pylorus
as a result milk in the stomach can't
pass into the small intestine which
causes the baby to forcefully vomit the
milk
the vomiting may cause severe
dehydration a condition in which the
body loses too much water
common symptoms of dehydration include
sunken eyes no tears when the baby cries
a sunken soft spot on the top of the
head and urinating less often or having
brown or dark yellow urine
fortunately the dehydration is not
immediately life-threatening
after the dehydration is treated the
baby will require an operation called a
pile or oh my oughtta me to open the
blocked pylorus this operation will be
done a month or two after birth when the
condition is discovered
before the operation the baby will be
given general anesthesia to put him or
her to sleep for the entire operation
a breathing tube will be inserted
through the nose or mouth and down the
throat to help the baby breathe during
the operation
commonly the surgeon will make three
tiny incisions near or in the belly
button and on the right and left sides
of the upper abdomen then small tubes
for a camera and surgical instruments
will be inserted through these incisions
the surgeon will carefully locate the
thickened pyloric sphincter
an incision will be made along the
outside of the pyloric sphincter the
incision will only pass through the
muscle layer leaving the inner tissue
lining intact
the surgeon will insert a surgical
instrument to widen the incision and
spread the muscle fibers apart
incision called a pile or oh my ah t'me
will loosen the pyloric sphincter muscle
so that stomach contractions will be
able to push food through the pylorus
into the small intestine
finally the surgeon will close the skin
incisions with dissolvable sutures and
skin closure strips
after the operation the baby will be
taken to the recovery room for
monitoring
pain medication will be given
feedings will begin shortly after the
operation
the baby will be released from a
hospital within one to two days once
they can feed normally and stay well
hydrated